martine michel david question du four
bonsoir bonsoir on a commencé cette
émission avec un cri du coeur de deux
médecins les médecins important qui une
pneumologue et un chirurgien vasculaire
donc qui connaissent bien la machine
qu'ils disent
savez vous c'est triste à dire mais il
ya trop de gens qui viennent aux soins
intensifs qui ne devrait pas venir
donc ils prennent la place pourquoi il
ne devrait pas venir parce que leur
espérance de vie est vraiment trop
réduite
il n'y a pas de triage il parle pas du
triage éventuel qu'on devra faire en
deux malades ducobu de lampard du doj
actuellement c'est tabou mais c'est
comme ça entre des jeunes et des
personnes plus âgées dont l'espérance de
vie est faite je vous remets donc deux
extraits qu'on en parle après on traite
d'angély le patient coville distance
questionner si c'est probablement
qu'horrible de le traiter le patient
qu'ovide mais là est-ce que c'est
correct de délester ces gens là
plus on diminue la chance de survie
d'une tonne de personnes au détriment
des gens qui ont peut-être pas de
potentiel de survie
hors délestage on se met la tête dans le
sable et audi il n'y a pas de problème
ya pas de problème bien vrai problème il
ya du monde avec des cancers guérissable
qui ne seront pas guéri qui vont mourir
et ce pas un problème qu'on va rattraper
dans un mois deux mois quand on vote lui
c'est un problème dany on se reportera
pas de rattraper tout ça il ya du monde
au pays
ils m'ont cole aurait pu guérir qu'on
sera pas capable de lire le postulat est
un conte ne peut pas actuellement
traités tout le monde sont prêtés tout
le monde n'y aurait pas de problème
martin biron réaction quand vous avez
entendu ses médecins
ben ça va dans le sens de ce qu'on
entend hier au panel on a parlé du
délestage et en soirée un médecin
spécialiste qui m'a appelé qui connaît
très bien le réseau sur le québec
surtout québec sur l'ensemble du québec
et qui me disait ça va prendre 3 4 1
pour être capable de passer à travers
tout le délestage
il me disait aussi que le nombre
d'hôpitaux n'a pas suivi la démographie
particulièrement montréal
alors on est dans une situation où il
manque d'hôpitaux la population vieillit
les gens sont plus malades
on n'est pas capable de tout les soigner
et hop arrive une pandémie qui dure
depuis 10 mois l'on va ça sera pas long
que ça va faire un an alors on est dans
une situation où il faut faire des choix
et on est dans une tempête parfaite et
là ces médecins là ouvre le débat est
clairement ils ne veulent pas que ces
débats leur soient longs ils veulent
qu'on réussisse à bouger sans le dire
aussi clairement mais ce qu'ils veulent
puis j'ai tout entendu tout les extraits
d'entrevues que jean-sébastien en fait
il veut le meilleur triage actuellement
ils veulent qu ils s'aperçoivent que
déjà vraiment très très très très très
mauvais état qui débarque aux soins
intensifs et qui ont peu près pas
d'espérance de vie et c'est là qu'ils
disent oh attention là le cobp était pas
un passe pas pour entrer n'importe
carrossoise intense et shell david qu'en
pensez vous
disait est en écoute et le ministre le
premier ministre nous a écouté on
appelle on approche du point de
saturation on n'est pas encore là on en
est pas encore à décider qui on va
laisser mourir mais lorsqu'on attend
c'est que on est déjà là on n'attend pas
que les hôpitaux soit 10 à saturation
pour être en phase de choix des chirac
cela et ça c'est un peu je pense là
comment dire l'angle mort de la pandémie
c'est à dire que beaucoup de gestes
s'imaginent encore que le problème va se
terminer il a enfin le vaccin baru et
puis tout est réglé alors qu'on sait de
plus en plus on est plus en plus
conscients que les répercussions vont se
prolonger pendant des années que des
gens vont mourir lutter parce que
aujourd'hui on est obligé de faire ces
choix là dit il ça devrait être de
nature à conscientiser les gens se
délecter la libye lui ni tricherie qu'on
fait maintenant là ça va peut-être avoir
des effets non seulement sur le les gens
qui sont actuellement atteints de la
commune mais mais pour tous sur ti pour
d'autres raisons ont besoin de soins et
qui ne les auront pas de terga lire dix
mois depuis un mois je n'ai fait aucune
opération avec le ballon là pour ouvrir
les artères et les veines pour ceux qui
ont des problèmes cardiaques il dit il
ya des ces gens là puis a pris
l'expression qui vont péter sur la rue
il dit je sais pas combien je souhaite
qu'à n'est pas beaucoup mais c'est comme
ça alors c'est là qui dit qu' il
faudrait qu'on convaincre les familles
les jacks dans certains cas qu'un
patient atteint de la coved qui achètent
pas moi qui très âgées ne viennent pas
dans un centre généralisée ils sont
rendus là christian du four
oui c'est un débat difficile on touche
un sujet tabou comme vous l'avez dit
mais je suis content quand même que
certains médecins mais ouvert le débat
parce que dans la mesure où au mieux ce
que l'arrivée on allait jusqu'à un
certain point à ne pas être capable de
traiter tout le monde qui est malade on
n'a pas le choix je regarde aujourd'hui
on veut des échanges entre médecins sur
les réseaux sociaux sur ce thème là et
ça m'a frappé c'est qu'arnaud plusieurs
kills est c'est grave
dramatique c'est glauque mais faudrait
pas lui perd dramatiser il se met fait
méfier des médias ce qui est arrivé ce
qu on touche quand même à un espèce de
prendre de valeur c'est contre fois les
gens ne mettais beaucoup plus facilement
lorsqu'un bateau faisait naufrage par
exemple on faisait des femmes et les
enfants d'abord les fameuses en blanc
ces privilégiés
il coulait autrefois les par accepter
qu'on se sacrifie pour ses enfants
on est dans une société qui accepte
beaucoup moins c'est un peu ça le
problème
moi personnellement je pars juste pour
moi à mon âge vénérable
si je me retrouve à l'hôpital je vivre
compagnies mobiles mais j'ai eu une
belle vie j'ai eu des malheurs j'ai eu
des bonnes heures si on doit choisir
entre moi que ce soit et osant quelqu'un
qui a 40 ans quand je croise est la
personne avec arata ça me choque pas du
tout mais c'est pas tout le monde qui
passe du tout donc c'est vraiment on
ouvre on ouvre quelque chose tous est
nécessaire pour prévoir
c'est peut-être ça va être encore plus
dramatique ou quand même se doter
certains critères mais c'est pas évident
parce que pour beaucoup de gens c'est un
débat est en sable ou même pas discuter
ce nom que le droit à la vie mais en
quoi
oui à lézignan oui on peut pas demander
à des gens dont les parents par exemple
sont atteints de la copie de leur dire
non mais écoutez amené le pas l'hôpital
ça vaut pas la peine va faire de toute
façon est condamné on peut pas demander
ce que les médecins disent je comprends
ce que c'est on me dit
et beaucoup de gens sont d'accord avec
vous même et ses médecins le disent on
peut demander ça la famille si la
gravité du code de sa mère ou de son
père est tel que ya peu près aucune
espérance de vie contractée m existe
mais je pense que les gens réagiront pas
comme ça ils vont se dire c'est pas nous
a décidé ça nous on existe et soignés et
que eux prennent la responsabilité une
cache du us et les médecins ou les
comités de faire ce choix là nous enlève
papa mais la docteure francoeur a quand
même nommé le mot précis le mot clé
c'est dignité
il ya une compréhension et une façon
d'expliquer les choses c'est sûr que
quand on en parle devant un panel et que
votre mère à l'autre bout et dans un
siège chez celles des puisqu'elle peut
pas avoir deux visites ça devient un peu
plus compliqué mais si on est capable de
bien expliquer les choses d'année aussi
les gens aillent proches de leurs
proches
peut-être un autre niveau de
compréhension qui va s'établir
c'est ce qu'elle souhaite parce qu'elle
a mesuré ces mots docteur francoeur mais
c'est ce qu'elle disait c'est dans le
dialogue avec les familles parce qu'il
ya des cas trop lourd disait tél je
comprends ce que vous dites michel davy
mais ce que répondent les médecins ce
que vous dites disent oui mais l'homme
de 50 ans qui meurent la crise cardiaque
demain il n'est pas apparent lieu pas la
coved on en parle moins minima pour vrai
plein de femmes il oscille dans ce
monsieur là alors qu'on en comptait bien
là tout s'est parfaitement bien sûr mais
mais mais mais reste qu'à des gens qui
vont leur apprendre des décisions là
dedans puis moi je regardais aujourd'hui
le dossier dont on commençait la barre
et certains critères ça nous fait rare
de dire ça mais quand on prend en
considération les chances de survie
lâche tout ça je ne savais pas comment
je vais faire ce que je sais que c'est
bon mais mais en même temps il faut en
parler puis modja baby boom à moi ce qui
me frappe plus les gens de ma génération
ils veulent du 100 mètres le pont mûri
ils veulent pas il ya par les deux
sociétés là dedans un peu l'on touche à
quelque chose d'assez profond qui nous
touche tous
mais on n'a pas le choix pour l'abordage
comptable pas 13 heures que vous d'abord
impressionné
les médecins disent pas des têtes folles
les deux qui ont parlé ils ont réfléchi
avant de donner les entrevues à
jean-sébastien docteur galifi docteur
chagnon et c'est des gens très respecté
dans leur milieu qui vivent tous les
jours et qui disent il faut il faut
lancer ces débats là parce que nous on a
ces choix-là des choix silencieux qu'on
fait là parce qu'on laisse tomber du
monde actuellement on en laisse tomber
bon on va reparler
c'est c'est un engagement voire parle
évidemment commissaire à la lutte ou
reste je change totalement de sujet mais
je vais vous entends de bochra manaï qui
a été nommé par la ville de montréal
je vous montre une citation de monsieur
legault premier ministre qui a dit
aujourd'hui une très bonne nomination
dit il je résume et 10 nominations de
madame manage est questionnable compte
tenu de ses prises de positions partie
de sa croisade personnelle contre la loi
sur la laïcité la loi 21 qui maintenant
la loi donc pour nous il s'agit d'une
erreur de la part de la ville de
montréal madame mannaï donc on était
contre la loi 21 oui a plaidé contre ça
comme d'autres gens madame mannaï
hautement compétente et c'est ce qui
fait d'elle la candidate choisie a
répondu valérie plantes tour de table là
dessus quand pensez vous de
l'intervention du premier ministre de
tout ça christian dufour je serai avec
vous ça montre que c'est une mauvaise
décision pour que mais le prix miss
longoria juste tout de suite moi j'irais
même choisir si nous soit pour être
franc c'est un dossier très délicat qui
est très idéologique déjà il ya un
groupe partira si je pense montréal à
l'action qui a dit que cette décision
anti noirs parce qu'on n'avait pas nommé
une femme semble-t-il qu'il fallait même
une femme qui était noir voyez à quel
point on est on est dans l'idéologie
quelqu'un qui est au dessus la mêlée que
de la crise bulletins secrets portant ce
dossier là or la dame en question pour
nous dit qu'à 2 maîtrise et un doctorat
en fin de semaine les transmettre à la
lutte avec un militant
vous n'êtes pas seuls a milité contre à
l'époque le projet de loi 21
discréditée pendant que belhadj à moi
sur le plan et en plus c'est pas terminé
notre dos il ya beaucoup c'est que c'est
une femme qui a été éduqué en france
je m'excuse mais la relation du
gouvernement français avec les minorités
maghrébine des tunisiens les algériens
et les marocains les profondément
malsaine on n'a pas besoin de ça ici
quand on regarde la dossier je trouve
que moi je trouve que cinq six éléments
qui montrent même chaîne avait alors moi
je pas d'accord du tout ni avec monsieur
gougnan critias s'est pas passé du
national mixte une erreur que c'en est
une d'une part tout le monde a le droit
de contester une loi madame maintenant
il le fait avec la loi 21
la loi est adoptée la mairesse plante
aussi combattait la loire 21 est là le
dicter la loi est adapté on va aussi
confirmé s'y conformer et je ne doute
pas que madame manai fasse la même chose
et d'autre part son mandat ce n'est pas
la laïcité faut pas mélanger les choses
r la ville de montréal l'apport les
policiers il n'y a pas grand monde dans
l'appareil municipal qui est touché ou à
peu près personne qui est touchée par la
loi 21 c'est pas ça l'essentiel du
bandana d'amman à et sa voix est de
travailler sur le terrain aux problèmes
de racisme là où il ya peut-être un
problème est que monsieur leubou ne
nomme pas c'est que le titre de madame
van nuys ça va être le commissaire la
lutte contre le racisme et la
discrimination systémique au pluriel
ce qui sous-entend qu'il y a un problème
de la même chose la loi 21
mais vous vous êtes michel qu'est ce
qu'il vient faire à dire du haut de son
statut de premier ministre que la ville
de montréal n'a pas le droit d'engager
telle personne tel os martial quelqu'un
qui se plaint continuellement des
empiétements du gouvernement fédéral sur
les compétences du québec je trouve que
monsieur leubou devrait se garder une
petite gêne avant de critiquer les
nominations de la vie
de mourir parce qu'à montréal y en a eu
martin biron un certain nombre de
personnes qui avaient de grands doutes
vis-à-vis
à l'époque le projet de loi 21 beaucoup
la mairesse plante avait réclamé un
sursis elle ne voulait pas l'appliquer
dès l'adoption de la loi elle avait
demandé un an de délai moi j'y vois
beaucoup une manoeuvre politique là
c'est leur geste politique de la
mairesse plantes en année électorale le
premier geste qu'elle pose elle fait son
lit sur la question du racisme
systémique
monsieur legault je suis pas surprise
qu'ils aient réagi
il a parlé pas du tout madame planche
parce qu'il parlait à sa base électorale
qui est elle beaucoup plus cccc des
francophones ça ne touche pas du tout
monsieur le goût est peu présent
montréal c'est plus embêtant pour les
libéraux de dominique anglade que c'est
de réconcilier les francophones et les
allophones très content la nomination de
madame manage les seelandais se passe
aujourd'hui mais patrick patrick patrie
sont issus de la mairie
désolé l'allée des patrick tu faisais
des ponts au dessus de la mêlée allait
déjà très très controversé c'est une
militante on n'avait pas besoin de sedan
dans ce dossier moi j'en reviens pas que
je trouve que pour les gens qui veulent
vraiment la lutte contre le racisme
c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle c'est
sûr que ça peut l'arize le débat et
nappes autres de la loi 21 aurait fait
la même chose
oui bon ben c'est tout le temps qu'on a
c'est très bien débats jeux java lancé
il ya eu débat
merci beaucoup on veut revenir sur tes
sur d'autres sujets plus tard au revoir
[Musique]